[Musique]
bien nous sommes sur la scène de ce
sublime l'opéra de versailles qui va
fêter il fait ses 250 ans et pour leur
part les deux sens avec laurent brunelle
bonjour vous êtes le directeur de
versailles spectacles et vous qu'ils ou
plus vous occuper notamment de la
programmation de l'opéra
et puis nous sommes avec maxime ohayon
bonjour vous êtes le responsable de
mécénat du château de versailles
et puis vous êtes aussi l'ami du
compositeur et du librettiste des photos
de versailles cet opéra dont on va
parler également
on va peut-être commencer quand même par
ses 250 ans parce que j'avais dire au
fond deux cent cinquante ans d'histoire
nous contemplent oui c'est assez rare
d'être dans un bâtiment notamment un
théâtre qui soit six anciens et si bien
conserver ses biens concernés
alors le hasard de l'histoire fait que
comme notre père a n'est pas un opéra
pour le grand public à l'origine mais
pour la cour il est même encore plus
spécifique qui n'est fait que pour les
cérémonies des mariages princiers donc à
l'origine ces sahraouis et donc il a été
inauguré en 1770 pour le mariage de
marie antoinette et louis saez c'est le
16 mai exactement 16 e 16 mai 1770 donc
ans en 2020 16 mai également bien on
aura deux cent cinquante ans exactement
et dans les deux sens du mot c'est à
dire et le bâtiment et sinon mieux son
inauguration également et à l'époque
c'était pour trois soirs asseoir d'opéra
saint-adrien un soir de banquets où on
mettait les mariés une vingtaine sur une
grande table centrale et on les regarde
et banqueter et une soirée de bal avec
la partie nous sommes la scène la scène
et elle est la salle remise au même
niveau que la scène est donc on dansait
sur une espèce de très grandes val au
blond avec un plateau unique et sur
cette scène on mettait des décors de
balcons et les gens étaient sur des
balcons comme dans la salle
c'est incroyable c'est au palais opéra
parce qu'aujourd'hui on en parle à sa
tête un opéra blessés vrai qu'il a eu
plein de destination de ce lieu il a
surtout été et c'était ça l'idée non pas
ouvert tous les soirs mais ouverts pour
des cérémonies d'exception dis toujours
c'est un petit peu comme le mariage de
kate et william
et c'est un moment unique alors donc le
focal est porté sur ce moment et c'était
le lieu où se déroulait la grande
cérémonie du mariage comme si on avait
été à westminster même derrière une
colonne on aurait été content d'être
dedans
eh bien là c'est la même chose le nombre
de places est limité même si le plateau
est le plus grand des théâtres en europe
avant celui de l'opéra garnier ancien
club et a même inspiré dans l'opéra
garnier
alors partiellement on va dire que quand
garnier se pose des questions de
construction de son opéra il veut faire
un grand plateau et donc il vient voir
l'autre matin c'est celui ci est il
s'inspire de beaucoup de choses
notamment pour la circulation déjà à
l'opéra de versailles
dès qu'on quitte l'intérieur de la salle
pour être dans les couloirs les couloirs
sont tous en pierres ça brûle pas et la
peur d'un incendie dans un théâtre il ya
eu beaucoup d'incendiés dans la salle où
vous pouvez trouver du bois du tissu dès
que vous sortez de la salle par une
porte dans les circulations
il faut que tout soit en dur non
inflammable et garnier fait la même
chose
la situation des escales litres dont qui
s'inspire beaucoup de ce bâtiment
et puis bien sûr pour la scène de la
salle mais en son temps l'opéra que
fonctionne divorce fonctionne à
versailles et qui fonctionne ensuite à
garnier ou à peu près les mêmes
techniques et pas beaucoup changé en un
siècle
aujourd'hui c'est très différent et le
nôtre lui a conservé sa pente sur la
liste est-ce que la saignée on est en
descente là un petit peu notre avis on a
d'ailleurs on était obligé de mettre des
calots sièges sinon c'était comme une
luge
il ya aussi toutes ces mécanismes qui
sont entièrement on va dire suspendu et
manipulé à la main avec faut pas dire
cordes sur un terreau donc je ne vais
pas dire un de ses porte mal par contre
faut pas non plus des sièges vers ce qui
est la couleur de cela - avants ont fait
manipuler tout ça à la main et non pas
les criques mans alors ça donne bien sûr
aujourd'hui avait toujours toute façon
n'a pas d'électricité sur ces manoeuvres
là donc ça donne une grande précision
puis aussi une espèce de sensibilité
faire descendre un rideau à la main on
peut le faire plus doucement sur la fin
où l'enjeu alors qu'un moteur
il va faire marcher et puis
éventuellement il fait pas aussi bon
alors que a priori à la main alors ça
fait beaucoup de spécificités 1770
on est à moins de 20 ans de la
révolution
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans c'est
donc pendant ses 250 ans quand même
alors pendant les vingt ans avant la
révolution ça sert dans sa salle et
soirée mais ça sert peut il ya très peu
le soir annonce très peu presque une
fois par an ben oui c'est sympa c'est
par blocs de traits soir et c'est grâce
à fait disons très peu d'utilisation
c'est pas l'endroit où on joue les
spectacles tous les soirs ça c'est à
paris ou bien dans d'autres lieux à
versailles pour très peu de gens c'est
plutôt des petits morceaux d'opéra quand
j'entends ça à l'époque dans des salles
qu'on aménage et après la révolution
c'est comme le palais sa ferme
pendant des années il se passera plus
rien ici et il faudra attendre
grosso modo la guerre de 70 pour que le
gouvernement s'installant dans le
château après la défaite à dire tout
après l'arrêt après l'avènement de la
république on décide de mettre
l'assemblée nationale
à l'autre bout du château et le service
et n'a ici ici alors c'est une scène
idéale tel personnage puisque il ya déjà
les sièges
il ya déjà l'endroit du perchoir ça va
être le plateau et puis il suffit
simplement de retirer à la le plafond
peint et on met une verrière la place de
la lumière pour le pour les débats et ça
va rester dans cet état là jusqu'à en
gros jusqu'à la première guerre mondiale
et ensuite on va le remettre en état de
théâtre mais faudra attendre les années
voilà c est relativement vraiment faire
les travaux parce que le sénat était
encore il ya 12 ans de sa propriétaire
du bâtiment affecté les sénateurs
pourrait venir
pas tout à fait mise avec des logements
il y avait des logements et même les
loges qui nous servent de loges pour les
artistes
c'était des appartements pour les
saynètes de fonctionnaires du ses
fonctionnaires du sénat
voilà jusqu'à il ya dix ans et c'était
un peu compliqué de leur reprendre je
crois d'ailleurs non par an soit
compliqué mais quand vous avez des gens
qui habitent là de l'appartement est
contents d'habiter là voilà c'est ça il
était content et mais bon là on a repris
ce bâtiment un petit peu dans une
fonction différente qu'il n'avait jamais
eue c'était finalement de lui faire
jouer un rôle de théâtre dans un lieu
aussi chargé d'histoire que versailles
donc d'y jouer régulièrement et
aujourd'hui c'est une centaine de
représentations par an et aujourd'hui
alors
on en reparlera peut-être de notre
émission il ya une programmation
incroyable depuis depuis concède cinq
anticipent une sainte horreur de me
laisser ça là des news est admis qu en
ouais c'est ça c'est que vous êtes là
bas ça c'était ça et vous êtes venus
pour ça vous dire je suis pas venu pour
ça parce que si on m'avait demandé de
venir pour ça ils ont eu tort et m'ont
demandé de venir pour tout le reste tout
le reste ouverte
les spectacles et puis moi j'ai dit au
président de l'époque du château j'ai
dit mais l'opéra et du ballet opéra tu
peux faire ce que tu veux mais j'aimais
n'y a pas de budget il n'a rien dit bah
non il a rien pas de budget pas d'équipé
rien alors j'ai dit ok alors si je
trouve tout ça je garde ce que c'est en
france le vieux truc c'est quand vous
trouvez quelque chose on vous le prend
oui on vous entend déjà enterré à 15% en
impôts à la sortie à l'air libre si je
trouve le public l'argent les décors les
équipes on continue quoi on s'arrête pas
en chemin et donc ça c'est fait et
l'actuelle présidente catherine pégard
qui est une passionnée de spectacles pas
seulement la musique le théâtre et c est
bien pour ce projet ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui sans argent public et
c'est le seul ça oui c'est ça il n'ya
pas y'a pas un euro de vos impôts donc
une symphonie de votre tv a ici vous
achetez un billet vous savez vous avez
donné une somme et c'est celle-là votre
éco plus peut-être levé cenap
alors pour le savez le médecin me paie
aussi le pen mais cette peine voilà en
tout cas c'est un grain particulier il
joue un rôle dans on en parle dans un
sens avec maxime ouailles ont quand même
on va donc fêter ses 250 ans le 16 mai
prochain avec le ballet royal de la nuit
alors je crois si j'ai bien compris
est ce que c'est vrai que c'est le
premier ballet où louis xiv apparaît en
soleil alors louis xiv à danser dans des
ballets durant une vingtaine d'années ça
parlait énorme de sa prime jeunesse
jusqu'à quasiment sa prise de pouvoir
et quand ils dansent dans le ballet
royal de la nuit ils lancent plusieurs
rôles comme toujours et la cour dans
aussi de rappeler qu'il ya des
professionnels et ya les grands de la
cour qui sont excellents danseurs sans
doute louis xiv était peut-être un des
meilleurs danseurs de ses seins dans
nombre sont armés ils y passent plus de
trois heures d'exercice par jour ce qui
est considérable m'enfin l'époque il
était jeune et sur sa prime jeunesse il
n'est pas encore vraiment froid régnant
il est roi mais il ya un marin pour s'en
occuper à ce qu'on va appeler les
sphères de l'état
et quand ils dansent dans le ballet
royal de la nuit il est le personnage
principal donc ça passe entre guillemets
de la nuit au jour donc il apparaît au
matin en soleil et c'est la première
fois qu'il apparaît et qu'il prend cette
image du soleil et c'est très important
puisque dans ce ballet on retrouve
beaucoup des affrontements de l'époque
le sombre enfin je parle pas de la reine
de la nuit mais on n'y est quasiment le
sombre c'est par définition toutes les
forces du mal d'inconnues et al'inverse
le soleil soleil revient éclore
c'est ce roi peut-être aussi après la
fronde oui il ya des anciens frondeurs
qui danse dans le talent et il ya
vraiment une espèce de jeu de couret et
le banat tellement dessus c'est qu'on
donne plusieurs fois qu'on laisse venir
du public ce qui d'habitude ne se
faisait pas et il est vraiment fondateur
dans ce sens là peut-être qu'on avait
déjà donné des balais ou le droit danser
mais jamais ils n'avaient de venise est
devenue ce ce roi soleil qui restent
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
l'image qui va lui coller le plus avant
il a été on va dire plutôt apollon le
dieu de la beauté et le lieu des arts il
va le rester
il va devenir marx le dieu de la guerre
très rapidement mais fondamentalement il
nous aura sûrement un soleil alors il
sera ce volet sera programmé le 16 mai
c'est-à-dire jour pour jour les 250 ans
de l'opéra je vous propose d'en
d un extrait
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc c'était le extraits du ballet royal
de la nuit qui sera donnée ici même dans
cet opéra le 16 mai prochain
alors on va parler maintenant d'un opéra
qui s'appelle les fantômes de versailles
qui est important parce que il a été
donnée ici il était donné qu'en fin
d'année dernière il était donné en
novembre 2019 et l'idée de fêter cet
anniversaire de deux cent cinquante ans
on le fait sur une saison bien sûr parce
que dans les théâtres entre huy dans
l'autre sur la saison c'est la saison
des 250 ans et j'avais depuis que
j'étais là quelques oeuvres
emblématiques en me disant on ne va pas
y arriver mais on va essayer parce que
il n'y a qu'ici qu'elles ont du sens et
partout ailleurs on les donnera comme
une oeuvre est ici on et donnera à la
maison c'est vraiment la maison et il y
a une vingtaine d'années de sacs
aureliano peut-être même une trentaine
maintenant c'est le camp visiteur
le compositeur avait une commande du
metropolitan opera nous laisse entendus
est pour ses 100 ans
donc déjà une commande d'anniversaire et
il avait produit alors peut-être à
l'étonnement de tous à l'époque une
oeuvre qui s'appelle l'effort des fins
de versailles pour les salariés de
n'être beaumarchais voilà pourquoi les
100 ans du maître ça se passe finalement
vraiment dans l'opéra royal ça passe
dans les reins ou bon marché et marie
antoinette un peu beau marché amant ou
amoureux de marie antoinette va essayer
de transfigurer le destin pour essayer
de faire échapper la reine à les chasser
c'est incroyable alors il dit la
solution c'est de prendre le collier de
la reine qui a été alors un événement
politique absolument majeur à côté de ça
toutes nos affaires actuelles sont la
rigolade et de le faire disparaître donc
y aura plus le collier de la reine y
aura plus la ferté ça et peut-être
margrethe elle s'en sort et il écrit un
opéra ou bon marché voulant faire ça et
bien écrit mais parce que c'est beau
marché qui écrit un essai de sa
libération absolument incroyable mais
alors en même temps composés à la
manière de ces musique de rossini et de
mozart qui ont beaucoup mis en scène
beaumarchais qui fonctionne très bien et
ça se passe vraiment ici en costumes
d'époque
donc je m'étais dit un jour ça ça a du
sens ici et on a réussi à le faire on en
parle en classe prépa très vite
outre le fait que vous êtes le
responsable du mécénat nous est aussi
l'habit de john corigliano et de bill
hoffman qui le librettiste ouais c'est
ça qu'il allait rencontrer
oui j'ai bien connu
bill of mal et puis j'ai connu un peu
plus tardivement john corigliano et puis
c'est absolument extraordinaire pasqua
qui l'eût cru
vers 7 et ça a été qui l'eu cru qu'un
jour on allait pouvoir monter ça à
versailles je crois que dans les rêves
les plus fous du compositeur du
librettiste jamais il avait imaginé
qu'il se produirait sur la scène même
deux des personnages qu'ils avaient
quasiment inventé il ya ça et puis aussi
le côté un petit peu triste c'est que
bill hoffman n'a pas su malheureusement
que versailles allait reprendre cette
production il est décédé d'une crise
cardiaque en 2e août 2017
et ça c'est un peu triste parce qu'il
aurait été absolument extatique c'etait
un
c'était un francophile c'était un
francophone et d'ailleurs je l'avais
rencontrée dans des circonstances très
amusante
il était à l'époque bill hoffman donc le
librettiste de des fantômes de
versailles était à l'époque donc il
arrondissait ses fins de mois en faisant
les traductions des surtitres des
productions qui était pro pour présenter
à la brooklyn academy of music
donc il y avait une production en
français production habite encore été
décidé si oui comment on le fait ici
chez nous et donc il était chargé de
faire les surtitres en français d'une
production française qui avait été amené
à new york par william christie et les
arts florissants et il se trouve soudain
francophile
oui les mails il maîtriser
la culture française la littérature
française est plus ou moins la langue
française et se souvenir mais je l'avais
rencontrée dans des circonstances un
petit peu difficile parce qu'il s'était
fait il s'était fait que conspué il
s'était fait disputer par ce qu'il avait
fait une erreur de traduction qui avait
susciter le rire dans la salle
alors que quelque chose de dramatique se
joue et se jouer sur la scène
voilà donc c'est mon bon souvenir de
bill hoffman et puis et évidemment comme
je connaissais bien bill les fantômes de
versailles c'était sans grands
chefs-d'oeuvre parce que ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est ce que dit john corigliano
qui nous l'a encore répété
lorsqu'il était là pour les répétitions
et pour les représentations c'est que
bill of may n'a pas été que librettiste
c'est une collaboration entre le
compositeur à suivre la c2 et qu'ils ont
formé un espèce de binômes en symbiose
et ils se sont aidés mutuellement et il
en produit cette espèce de chose
absolument unique un opéra bouffe qui
part dans tous les sens mais qui a à la
fois du génie dans l'écriture musicale
et du génie dans dans l'écriture du
livret est ce que c'est
c'est une vie parce que ce sont des
américains est ce que c'est un peu une
vision américaine de versailles un peu
comme ça à peu romancée à peu romanesque
hop c'est une vision qui n'a pas la
révolution française comme grille de
lecture pour baisser parce que quand on
sort de france louis xiv et
marie-antoinette sont presque aussi
important dans l'autre marie antoinette
c'est lady diana c'est une reine qui
meurent jeunes elle meurt à la au même
âge que mozart et ils sont nés à peu
près la même date
d'ailleurs ils ont qu'à voir le film de
coppola afin de voir assez ça et pour
eux c'était un destin tragique hier
c'est une reine qui a quand même pas
tout fait pour l'échafaud et qui est pas
une espionne de l'autriche qui manipule
pas par contre elle est prise dans
l'espèce de tourbillon de l'histoire une
manière les plus victimes que oui vol
capable alors en tant que tel en asie ou
aux états unis
il s'est vraiment un personnage clé de
l'histoire de france
en france c'est madame veto c'est de la
brioche et c'est très puissant on reste
sur louis xiii qui est un roi qui était
gros qui s'intéressent et concerts
l'ucv que louis saez lisez tous les
matins la presse anglaise dans le texte
qu'il avait après lui-même
voilà on a on a une image clichés et
quelque part très hérité de la
république durant un siècle et demi de
seix et qui donne peut-être pas
exactement une vision juste de ça alors
évidemment ils ont une vision dans ce
livre est d'abord burlesque
parce que c'est une oeuvre drôle et puis
ensuite avec ce détachement que permet
deux siècles et demi d'histoire
américaine enfin un dernier détail marie
antoinette et louis saez
ce sont eux qui donnent la liberté aux
états unis qui envoient des troupes pour
permettre ce qu'on va appeler nous
l'indépendance de l'amérique et la
déclaration des droits c'est louis saez
et pour eux devant la maison blanche
c'est le square lafayette
c'est un pas un détail du pays donc le
lien entre la france et des états unis
il passe bien sûr par cette reine ce roi
lafayette et d'autres pas du tout sous
le même angle de ce qu'on va voir en
france nous on a une vision évidemment
hérité de nos conflits politiques
finalement interne alors que là il y as
peut-être plus la reine que l'histoire
aurait pu la sauver
on va essayer en subrepticement en
planquant le collier de la reine
évidemment ça marche plus ou moins bien
c'est ça qui permet un rebondissement et
la reine va jusqu à l'échafaud ce que je
fais quelque part enfin on n'a aucun
spectacle de théâtre ambiance incroyable
n'y en a jamais eu vous marie antoinette
est le personnage principal et va jusqu
à l'échafaud n'ya pas alors c'est
intéressant
les américains ou les anglo saxons isoz
ont toujours eu une vision sur la
politique même de leur époque mais très
forte dans le spectacle c'est simple
c'est vrai que c'est pourri c'est très
américain ça on peut parler de la
plastique très vite et même très vite
après les événements mais manque
beaucoup et vite que nos enfants qui
sont enfin c'est que c'est une réalité
les moyens oui il ya aussi une anecdote
qu'il faut qu'ils rapportaient dans les
fantômes de versailles
l'anecdote qui fait qu' on avait
organisé la fuite de marie-antoinette
vers les états unis et aux états unis à
philadelphie il y avait une congrégation
qui s'apprêtait à recevoir et ça c'est
vrai oui c'est que l'on retrouve dans la
pièce alors je vous propose puisque le
l'opéra les batteries blé les fantômes
de versailles va être diffusée sur télé
78 pour vous d'en voir un extrait puis
on se retrouve tout de suite après
[Musique]
alors maximois y ont peut-être un mot
quand même de ce qu'elle met ses doigts
parce que c'est important vous me disiez
voilà c'est dit pas avec de l'argent
public chacun paye ses places ce qui est
plus moral dans les rarissimes dans les
opéras parce que j'avais j'avais cru
comprendre par exemple l'opéra de paris
le prix de ce que payent les spectateurs
et c'est un peu peanuts dans donc
fonctionnement c'est le modèle
économique de la musique que nous et non
de cet art qu'est l'opéra impossible de
gagner de l'argent avec
c'est le seul c'est le seul comme dirait
c'est le seul business dans lequel vous
investissez 2 euros pour éventuellement
en gagner un
ces connaisseurs et donc il ya une
partie qui doit être prise en charge par
par les subventions ou par le mécénat
alors ce qui nous concerne nous avons
des recettes de billetterie qui sont
extrêmement fortes mais ça ne suffit pas
et la partie qui nous permet
d'équilibrer les comptes et bien il ya
une partie de mécénat particulier donc
des individus qui nous suivent ya des
entreprises qui nous suivent
et puis il ya aussi la possibilité
d'utiliser ce lieu extraordinaire pour
des soirées d'entreprise on ne peut pas
faire mieux c'est un bijou fantastique
s'il en a mais c'est dans la foi
d'entreprise est pris et particuliers
particulier très fort et entreprises
aussi des particuliers qui à partir de
400 euros son mécène drainera avec une
déduction fiscale bien son parle pas de
gens qui sont tous richissime et qui
viennent faire un club excluant leur est
pas du tout mais ça commence à 400 bien
sûr oui c'est une petite pierre portet
avec amour fait des vrais construction
notamment l'opéra royal
ce qui est important à dire c'est que
allez-y non alors ce qui est important à
dire c'est que quand vous achetez votre
place
deux spectacles ça ne paye encore pas la
production donc si vous pouvez faire un
petit peu mieux que simplement votre
espace de spectacle bienvenue on voit
bien le responsable merci infiniment
maxime retrouver un de ces cas pour
parler de la programmation de cette
année magnifique puisque ce celle des
250 ans de l'opéra de versailles
merci merci infiniment à tous les deux
même si patrice
[Musique]